Then if you talk about the neck part, then
what will you get in the neck part, son, here it will contain the
centrals. What do
you get in it, you get centrioles right
which basically
helps you in fertilization as well as cleavage. Then if you in the
third part  If we talk about that is the middle piece,
then what do you find in the middle piece? You find a lot
of mitochondria and on this the
question comes that which is the energy
source of the human sperm, then who is the
energy source that is the middle because what is
inside it?  Present is your
mitochondria which will
form your energy and then the last
part is your tail part which we all know will
act as the plasma and how it
will help, it will help in the movement of sperm.
Right, this is a very basic structure.
Related to the Human
Spam